uh
give me your top five spank bank top
five girls in your spank make now let me
explain you what this means
this is the top five women
you're like if you could bang any chick
in the world for example like for me my
whole life
jlo has been like the pinnacle of
of hot celebrity chicks i want to sleep
with you
so she's like my wife's in my top five
one through five obviously
but jayla would be sixth yeah you had to
say that of course shout out to my wife
i won't show you pictures of my wife by
the way this [ __ ] guy right here
no i ain't gonna do that right here
nia long [ __ ] legend christina
million
okay you got a chance there she's been
with a lot of artists
i want to say she was with the dream
nick cannon and lil wayne
all three yeah you got a chance for
christina milion
that's very realistic
right now oh my god are you crazy he's
sliding in christina millions dms as we
speak
i respect the [ __ ] oh my god he's
really dope
[Music]
it's it's it's official
all right so we got christina million
nia long who else the on christina
miliant
she's so far um neil on
christina milia um
man would rihanna crack your top five
i love her i feel like her [ __ ] is so
good
something about her her [ __ ] just good
i feel like that there's reason to
believe that that might be true rihanna
brianna yeah christina milia nia long
rihanna
iggy iggy azalea yes well she just broke
up with the
the playboy cardi guy so you got a
chance there where is she
she lives out here no what like what
race is she australian
so is that white yeah she's just a she's
just a [ __ ] genius
crazy bro i've never had no white [ __ ]
you know what's crazy is i
have had white vagina but i'm a white
man and i've
98 black girls i like anything but white
women
is your wife oh no your wife is mexican
eggs
yeah i don't [ __ ] with white girls not
my cup of tea sir
yo that [ __ ] it's so crazy i've never
been with a white girl but like
oh coming soon bro you're about to
[ __ ] you're about to be like you're
about to have a show and
once you go overseas is over but you're
about to like be in some random ass like
boise idaho
and it's only white women so boom
so hold on i saw who i said nia long
rihanna
iggy christina miller one more christina
hmm this last one gotta be it though
like
name some girls um
not cause i just can't think of so many
girls i i [ __ ] i mean you want me to go
old school
new school school i mean
there's some beautiful women in the
world right now shh
i won't lie like some you know sweetie
is beautiful but she's obviously in a
relationship with the homie
i'm about to say um not not her though i
was about to say like
it's a lot of uh like females who are
[ __ ] but it's these rap [ __ ]
girlfriends yeah you don't wanna you
don't wanna yeah you don't wanna be
disrespectful i mean i'm gonna keep it
respectful right
i won't talk about her now if if they
were in jail you wouldn't keep it
respectful because that's your ammo
you know oh i have no choice somebody
got to do it
this is true somebody's got to do it and
it's going to be this guy that's going
to be me
um one more eye boom let me think man
let me think uh uh
okay preface it by saying if she was
single this would be a single
oh she is then [ __ ] let it fly let it
fly who gives a [ __ ]
ah let it fly
bruh if she's single who cares
the only person you can mention he's
gonna get me
the only person you can mention that
would stir up some [ __ ] where you like
ruin your career is like maybe beyonce
but it wouldn't ruin your career but
yo i love beyonce no no no no no no
i didn't mean to say that hey look i saw
it's one you got you got limits i can't
say that guys
crazy nah yeah he he has limits but your
limits is like people like beyonce
i can't fight yo beyonce nicki minaj
you can't do that no no no the barbs are
crazy facts
okay so but know what i was gonna say i
love beyonce of course
but like you a [ __ ] respect
jay-z so much worse yeah
i wouldn't even have bring them give me
the name that you were gonna say so
we're gonna take them out of the
conversation what's the name you were
gonna say hey jay if you ever wanna come
talk to me bro like
my [ __ ] bro i [ __ ] with you for sophie
yeah yeah people don't realize you from
syracuse originally
i'm from new york [ __ ] but give me the
name you were gonna say
oh just stir it up [ __ ] it we
listen bro all right
but now real [ __ ] though i i
[ __ ] ruby rose ruby rose
yes she hasn't only fans yeah did you
did you subscribe but that's my friend
though
so she's your friend but you'd [ __ ] her
yeah
no no no no no no we don't had a crazy
interview
now i gotta i gotta know i don't
i don't [ __ ] with nobody right right
like i don't but i don't lie like by the
time this interview come out
i might have a girlfriend you might so
let's just be clear
so that's what i'm saying right this is
november 4th this is november 4th
so you might have a girlfriend so so
just we got to preface that so look
cause
it's this one girl that you like that's
that's yeah she's like your main main
for show like you see the potential
like yeah out of the gate she got it all
she got everything
so ruby rose is number five next but
when me when i get with shorty just
really girls yeah i ain't even
she popular if no no that's the way i
should be chilling but
i i won't lie like she got like 100 000
followers now
like but like
she had like 2 000 at first
oh [ __ ] yeah so [ __ ] got crazy like and
they started following her [ __ ] but
samaria samaria uh davis oh you just put
it out there well with that sir we're
gonna
end the interview facts hey man uh i
don't mind cause everybody know and it's
like
i know these rap [ __ ] gonna try to
[ __ ] with her but she like one of them
like shouldn't give a [ __ ] about
none of these [ __ ] well listen man if
y'all slaughter her i'ma let y'all know
right now like
come see me man i'm i'm ready to die
about that [ __ ] well god damn